Good day, cheers to Andrés González Today
is Wednesday, September 22 and these
are the most relevant news of the day.
The day of the ix cap 2021 final has arrived
and all the excitement of that great
sports confrontation will take
place here at the Ali stadium.  gen de las
vegas thousands of spectators and
soccer fans will join the club león
de mexico opens in front of the sky sanders of
ms the doors of the stadium will open at
5 in the afternoon but the game starts
at 7 at night they show up because they
still  tickets are available
or two deaths Tuesday following two
separate shootings just hours
apart one happened east of the valley
and the other near downtown
one of the incidents was a
training near 11th and
louis streets Tuesday night  morning when
agents arrived at the scene a man
ran and barricaded himself in an
abandoned building the situation escalated and they
had to request the help of
the most renowned special tactics squad
named as swap according to police
suspect started shooting so
officers fired at subject who
died on scene no one else was
injured second
officer-involved shooting happened near
charleston streets and highway 95 according
to people police there are two  agents from his
special tactics squad
shot an armed person it was not
clear what the suspect was doing and what
prompted the deployment of agents and
police but no one was injured in
this incident
las vegas' eggs are back
in the stadium pick this  sunday but
a reminder viewers have to
have at least one coronavirus vaccine shot to gain
entry they can also use the
clear app to check their
vaccination status there is an
alternate check station set
up offline be ok in lot v y  They are
open from Friday to Sunday from 9 a.m. to
2 p.m.
and let's see what the forecast has in store for us
weather forecast today is the first day of fall
but the temperatures are
still summery we will have a high of 97
degrees and will stay that way for the rest
of the week today we will have
cloudy skies and winds at night that
will bring smoke from the
california fires  Have an excellent day
andrés gonzález informs you this was
about the eimish now news in
Spanish